Hey everyone, my name is Aperna. I'm one
of the founders of Arise and today we're
going to talk about agent evaluation. At
Arise, we build development tools to
help teams build agents and take them
all the way to production. We focus on
everything from evaluation to
observability monitoring and in tracing
your application so you can see every
single step that your application took.
Uh let me tell you a little bit about
why we got into this and then I'll jump
into uh some concrete tips about how we
think about evaluating agents. First,
building agents is incredibly hard.
There is a lot of iteration that goes on
at the prompt level, at the model level,
at iterating on the different tool call
definitions. And for a lot of teams,
this is what their experience looks
like. They're in an Excel sheet. They're
swapping out different prompts. They're
trying to figure out did one prompt give
them a better output than another
prompt. Often a lot of this is just
based off of how it felt on a couple
different examples and then they go live
into production of that prompt. Part of
this is that it's it's pretty difficult
to actually systematically track where
is this new prompt doing better than
your previous prompts, where is this
model doing better. Um, and it's hard to
actually include other people,
especially if you have your product
managers or your thememes actually a
part of this iterative
evaluationdriven process to how you
actually want to think about improving
your application. Um, and so it's hard
to consistently figure out what makes
your agent better. And it doesn't get
easier once you actually deploy into
production. It's pretty hard to
understand, well, where's the
bottlenecks in my application? Is there
a specific sub agent or tool call that
is kind of kind of consistently
creating, you know, poor responses? How
do I want to actually identify those
bottlenecks and then what do I actually
need to do to go fix it? And so today
I'm going to be diving into a little bit
of the different components of how I
think about agent evaluations. We're
going to talk about some of the most
common components, which is evaluating
at the tool call level. um taking that
one step further going all the way to
the trajectory and looking at did it
actually um maybe across an entire trace
or or you know did it actually call for
example all the tool calls in the right
order. We're going to then not only look
across a single trace but then across um
multi-turn conversations because these
these interactions are no longer just
kind of a single turn experience. are
often multi-turn, keeping track of what
happened in the previous um interaction
and keeping that in mind as context for
the next um next turn of the
conversation. Uh so we're going to talk
a little bit about that and then I'm
going to jump into kind of a you know
approach that we've been really excited
about which is how do we get these
agents to self-improve and that starts
with not just thinking about the agent
improving but also your eval
consistently improving. So with that
let's jump in. I'm going to do a little
bit of slides and then I'm going to jump
into actually a real example so you guys
can actually see it in in practice. So,
first we're going to talk a little bit
about tool calling emails. Um, anyone
who's building agents is probably
writing a lot of different tools um and
making sure that your agent has access
to call all these different tools uh
depending on the action it needs to
take. And pretty consistently it's your
your agent needs to probably make the
decision of what's the right tool call
to call in this specific scenario. I
have you know potentially contacts from
previous part of a conversation or
previous actions it's taken and what do
I actually need to call in order to kind
of next continue whatever is happening
in that in that interaction. Um, so not
only do you have to pick the right tool
call, but you also have to figure out
from that conversation or or context,
what's the right arguments to pass into
that tool call. Um, and so it's pretty
important to actually evaluate, did it
call the right tool? Um, and did it pass
the right arguments into that tool call
itself. And I'm going to go into a
little bit of depth of this and show you
how we think about eval uh, actually
from from a product perspective. Um,
this is the Arise product. You can see
here I'm actually uh tracing and looking
at the traces of our own actually
co-pilot here. So this is our own
co-pilot and our own um agent that
actually think about it almost like an
insights um a tool where teams can come
in and ask all sorts of different
questions about where their application
is doing well or not doing well and use
this to actually troubleshoot their
their application and and suggest
improvements. And you know like any
great product we actually dog food our
own tooling. And so these are actually
the traces of different questions that
users have asked us. Um and we actually
evaluate uh these interactions so we can
understand where our co-pilot's doing
really well and where it's actually not
doing well. Um, one thing that we we
actually like to look a lot at is not
just kind of the individual traces, but
actually starting at a little bit more
of a higher level view where we can look
across all the different paths that, you
know, all the different, you know,
trajectories that our agent actually um
can can go down. So in our case, this is
actually the architecture of our agent.
You can see here we we follow a little
bit of an orchestration worker type
pattern where there's at the very high
level a a planner that decides based off
of the information um what to go down
and there's all sorts of different tools
that it can then call and sometimes
depending on the output of those tools
it might need to call even another um
router or orchestrator to figure out um
you know what next tool call to actually
call. And so there's kind of multiple
levels to this to actually make sure
that ultimately we respond to the user
in kind of a a a good a good way. um
with this specific agent of ours um you
can see here that you know for me what I
really think of a lot about is well at
the planner level at the the very
beginning uh is you know all across all
the different paths that this agent
could go where is it kind of doing
really well and are there any
bottlenecks in performance and as I can
look through some of this it's you know
there's evals around questions that that
are just related to you know generic
questions that the user is asking Um, it
looks like we're actually not doing so
well on search. I can see here we're
almost pretty consistently doing, you
know, it's about half and half of times
we're getting it correct as we're
getting it incorrect, which is not that
great. So, this is probably an area that
I would dive into and look at kind of
the bottlenecks uh of, you know, where
we're not doing so well when the user is
asking search questions. Um, and it
looks like there's other questions that
we're actually doing doing pretty good
on. So this type of highle view first is
just giving me a view of all the
different paths that my agent can go
down and really kind of pinpointing to
me what I should go focus on
specifically. So now when I go look
inside of my traces, I can actually uh
start with something like the Q&A
correctness and look at something like
well I I should probably care about um
in this case it was specifically the
search Q&A correctness. So, what I
should probably go look at is for search
Q&A correctness when it's incorrect. Let
me go take a look at some of the
examples of that and try to understand
where what I'm doing wrong here. And so,
in this case, when I'm looking at these,
I can actually now drill and go into
specific um traces. And at this level, I
have evals across the entire trace. I
have
evalu tool call level I also have um you
know not only did it call the right tool
call it says the function call is
correct but I also have eval on did it
actually pass all the right arguments in
this case it looks like that's where
it's going wrong it says therefore the
arguments do not align with the required
parameters leading to the conclusion
that the arguments are incorrect so I
probably have an issue here where even
though I'm calling it looks like the
right tool call um out of all the
different ones that I have, it looks
like maybe I'm not passing in the right
arguments inside of my tool call based
on the context of the conversation. So
that's something that I should go fix.
Um so this is kind of the first big one
that that we think a lot about. Um the
next one that it's pretty interesting is
also, you know, for a lot of these it's
not just a single tool call that's made.
It's many actually. And you can kind of
see that when when I was showing you the
way that our architecture is built.
There's actually a lot of different even
within the Q&A correctness. Uh when we
go down the search correctness path,
there's actually a lot of different
subtools that are even called here. So
it's pretty important to not only get uh
you know if it's individually calling a
single tool correctly, but also is it
getting the order of the tools that it's
supposed to call correctly. And that's
really what as as we think about
trajectory eval starts to uh starts to
it starts to become about is really is
it calling tool calls in the right order
um if across a series of steps that's
needed for an agent to complete a task.
Is it consistently calling and and
executing them in the same set of steps
or and and eventually converge on you
know x number of steps to complete this
action or does it sometimes veer off and
call it in a different order and
therefore require me to a have to spend
a lot of tokens in order to do the same
ask um and then b is it kind of messing
up and providing wrong kind of outputs
because of that. And so we recommend
teams to actually drill in and look at,
you know, across not just an individual
kind of a tool call, but actually
looking across um an entire trace and
looking at the order of the tool calls
to see if that's actually done well and
then evaluating kind of is overall in
this case I have it incorrect and so in
this case is it actually consistently
getting the tool calling order
correctness
uh uh correct. Um the next step here is
well you can look across a single
individual trace or interaction but a
lot of these interactions we're seeing
with agents actually ends up being
multi-turn. So in this case I have like
a three back and forths between a human
and an agent and there's a lot of
interesting questions you can actually
ask at this stage. You can ask questions
like is the agent consistent in tone? Um
is the agent maybe asking the same
question and again and again? um in
which case it's not really learning
anything from the previous interactions
that it's had with the human. Um and and
part of that is really does it keep
track of context from the previous kind
of n minus one turns in order to be able
to answer the nth uh turn of that
conversation really well. And so these
are all the types of questions to think
about when you have something that that
is
multi-turn. And I'll actually show you
an example from another project here
where I do have kind of some of that
multi-turn interaction. Um, this is
maybe one where I have kind of this back
and forth with with an agent. And what I
care about here across this entire
conversation is did I actually correctly
answer all the questions? Did I actually
make sure I kept context so that I
wasn't kind of missing context that was
made earlier in the conversation? And so
deeply recommend folks to actually think
about session evaluations as part of
their evaluating of agents. Um and then
lastly, I'll kind of go through this and
um I think this will be kind of a good
spot for us to um deep dive into which
is we spent a lot of time even just now
on the tool calling trajectory session a
lot talking about how to think about
evaluating the agent or the application
prompt. And this is really important. I
mean I we could spend a whole deep dive
on this itself but it's really important
to evaluate it correctly identify where
does it go wrong so that you can
annotate or you you know refine those
outputs and use those to actually
improve your existing prompt. And I
think a lot of teams actually totally
get this and are doing this all the time
to improve the agent prompt. Um, but
what's really important is that the
emails that you're actually using, which
is kind of the crux of how you identify
those failure cases, end up becoming
crucial to calling out what you need to
improve. And you don't want those eval
to remain static, the prompts for those
eval. And so there really is kind of
another loop going on here, which is
about improving the eval prompts. And
part of this is you're collecting um
consistently checking the the eval
outcomes as well to make sure it's not
just the application that got it wrong,
but it could have been the eval that you
know miscorrectly labeled it as wrong.
Um and start to identify where the eval
might need some improvements. And
similar to the process you did for the
agent application, do a workflow where
you're iterating on the eval prompts. um
you know building up a golden data set
consistently refining it. And there
really are kind of two iterative loops
kind of going on at the same time. One
for the agent evaluations, one for um
your your agent application prompts and
then one for your eval prompts. And as
you think about this, both of them kind
of go hand inand to actually create a
really good product experience um for
teams. Um, there's a lot more in here
that, you know, I I think we we can dive
into, but um, hopefully this gives you a
little bit of a primer about how to
think about agent evaluations. And, uh,
check out Arise Phoenix. It's a
completely open-source um, product that
you can use to learn a lot about what we
just went through and test it out in
your own applications. Um, you could
check out Riseex if you want to um,
think about how to run a lot of these
evaluations on your own data. Um, so
feel free to check it out and hopefully
you guys got something out of this.
Thanks everyone for the time.